please just don't vote don't vote don't  vote don't vote no seriously don't if  you uh care about Social Security what's  the point don't don't vote don't vote  really you care about the war on drugs  seriously do not vote voting is absurd  this is one of the biggest financial  disasters in American history the  economy's in the toilet who gives a [ __ ]  don't out of the question don't vote you  care about gun control Second Amendment  do not boat why would you vote why would  you vote I care play scrabble on this  thing or poker or whatever you're doing  or porn I'm gonna take off my bra under  my shirt don't vote whatever you do  don't vote nobody's listening to you so  hey you know what we got we got it we  get we gotta go no it's important oh no  huh you're right don't vote it's a bad  idea you know that right